[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Juliette riaño
[Música]
los cambios en las políticas migratorias
de algunos países de América Latina
terminan en el retorno de miles de
venezolanos a su país en Perú por
ejemplo segundo país de acogida en la
región después de Colombia las
autoridades están endureciendo el trato
a los ciudadanos extranjeros que se
encuentran en situación irregular un
país en el que además se denuncia
discriminación y xenofobia nuestro
corresponsal en Lima Francisco Zacarías
nos cuenta la situación actual de los
migrantes venezolanos en el país
Ángel Cabrera es un profesional en
mecánica automotriz que está preocupado
porque Perú expulsará a los extranjeros
que se encuentren ilegalmente en el país
por eso ha aplicado a una amnistía
migratoria que le permitía quedarse en
la nación andina los derechos humanos
tienen que estar por encima de todo y
respetarse las leyes para para todos los
extranjeros Tienen que darle la respetar
su condición de vulnerabilidad este para
que y darle la facilidades obviamente
según cifras oficiales entre 300.000 y
400.000 venezolanos se encuentran
ilegalmente en Perú la presidenta Dina
boluarte anunció cambios a la ley de
extranjería y acusó a los migrantes
venezolanos y haitianos de serlo
culpables de la criminalidad en el país
en paralelo el congreso Busca sancionar
con diez años de cárcel a los
venezolanos que ingresen ilegalmente al
territorio peruano y multará a los
arrendadores que alquilan viviendas
extranjeros en calidad migratoria y
regular
esta Norma preocupa a Carlos Velasco un
técnico en telefonía quien vive
legalmente desde hace cinco años en este
país y se dedica a la venta de golosinas
para mantener a su familia Él cree que
la ley perjudicará a todos los
venezolanos decir que tienes un
venezolano viviente notificar la
migración y si no lo tienes tienes que
multarlo solamente a propietarios sino
que pueden sacar a uno creo que me
parece que es una medida muy muy
drástica y violatoria para los Derechos
Humanos diversos organismos condenan que
en Perú se incite a la discriminación y
xenofobia hacia los venezolanos
constante generación de espacios para la
xenofobia y de estigmatización de la
población refugiada inmigrante
venezolana entonces una suerte de de de
de embates que a diario tiene que
afrontar la población refugiada de
migrantes de nacionalidad venezolana
mientras en la frontera con chile
cientos de migrantes venezolanos ruegan
por ingresar al territorio peruano la
mayoría de los que se encuentran en esta
nación luchan porque los dejen trabajar
y vivir libremente pero son Víctimas de
la discriminación y xenofobia
entre abril y mayo al menos 200 personas
quedaron bloqueadas en la frontera norte
de chile en los límites con Perú la
razón un nuevo Éxodo hacia el norte
desde un país que acogió a miles de
inmigrantes Pero que endurecía sus
políticas contra los extranjeros para
algunos el tránsito era el camino hacia
el retorno repasemos la situación en el
siguiente informe
Corren los primeros días de mayo en la
frontera entre chile y Perú carpas
improvisadas fueron ubicadas a un lado
de la vía que une a ambos países en
medio del desierto decenas de personas
esperan un permiso para continuar su
viaje al norte pero aquí encuentran un
muro invisible me vengo con la esperanza
de que las noticias sale que puedo venir
con el pasaporte sellado en Perú y puedo
pasar o con carne de extranjería de
peruano y resulta que cuando llego acá
me encuentro que los policías no nos
dejan pasar por nada del mundo porque yo
dicen que no que tengo que tener una
visa de tengo que tener definitiva de
chile Durante este año los controles se
intensificaron para los venezolanos en
Chile el parlamento aprobó leyes que
endurecen los controles migratorios y la
fiscalía ordenó la prisión preventiva
para los extranjeros sin papeles que
fueran detenidos por cualquier delito
con los venezolanos
empezaron a buscar Entonces ahora yo
nunca he estado preso en mi país y aquí
voy a estar preso por trabajar
Simplemente porque uno no tiene papeles
Entonces no no Es lógico decidido y
decidirme Exactamente para Venezuela
tres días varados aquí y choques contra
uniformados en la frontera
[Música]
un avión fletado por el gobierno
venezolano les garantizó el retorno
bueno la últimamente las reglas y las
leyes de chile se pusieron un poco
fuerte para nosotros para conseguir
trabajo Fue un poco complicado sin
embargo bueno tuvimos que tomar la
decisión de regresar
algunas horas de vuelo Nos llevaron a su
país nuevamente un país que dejaron en
busca de mejores condiciones de vida
pero al que vuelven lejos de las
restricciones en los países que alguna
vez los acogieron en total 115
venezolanos volvieron a casa
porque fue mucha pérdida de dinero
llegar hasta allá y devolverte tan
rápido sabes pero te voy a decir algo o
sea la familia es lo primero la familia
y como ves ahí están todos
este bus supone el tramo final de un
viaje que no saben si volverán a hacer
pero que por ahora los lleva a una
seguridad acompañados de sus seres
queridos a quienes dejaron por algunos
años según el gobierno de Venezuela más
de 340.000 venezolanos habrían retornado
al país esto sin especificar ni la
procedencia ni el periodo de los
reingresos chile por su parte reportó
que al menos dos mil extranjeros dejaron
su territorio Durante los primeros meses
de 2023
hasta que inmigrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrante f-24
sigan con más información en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]